it's only the start of fire season in
the amazon
but it's already the worst in a decade
brazil's national institute for space
research is reporting a total of 6
300 blazes in july 28 percent more than
for the same period
in 2019 environment minister hikaru
sales
says measures are being taken to prevent
last year's tragedy from repeating
itself
we are sending an additional 3 000
firefighters and more aircrafts to
protect the forests and prevent their
destruction
in july the government banned fires for
120 days in the amazon and bandana
regions
farmers have been forbidden from burning
vegetation to clear their land during
the dry season
but that hasn't stopped them it took one
farmer in the northern state of para
half an hour to clear his land
by the time satellites and local
authorities spotted the
fire it was too late
we perform a satellite analysis which
gives us information about where these
infractions are taking place
and based on that we search the system
and also identify
who owns this area while president
bolsonaro has been criticized for
downplaying the fires
the government is on a public relations
campaign to prevent a repeat of last
year's global backlash
especially after investors threaten to
divest if brazil fails to curb
environmental destruction last year
bolsonaro falsely accused actor
and environmentalist leonardo dicaprio
of funding
fires in the amazon rainforest this year
brazil's vice president amir tomorrow
invited the hollywood actor for an
eight-hour march in the jungle
so he could see for himself how
difficult
it is to protect such a huge area
morale has deployed thousands of
military to protect the rain forest
but the local kaiapa indigenous tribe
already fearful of kovit 19
say they feel far from safe believing
the fires as much as a threat
as the disease monika yanakiv al-jazeera
rio de janeiro